YURI GRINSHTEYN: We covered
monitoring GKE clusters
all the way back in
our first episode.
But there are lots of new
features in Cloud Operations
to help you observe and
manage your GKE clusters
and the workloads
that run on them.
Today, I'm going to show you how
to use Cloud Operations for GKE
to make sure your
services are healthy.
This is a Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Right away you'll see that
the new GKE Monitoring
Dashboard looks very different.
Instead of three
tabs, you now have
lists of all the different
GKE entities, like clusters,
namespaces, and nodes.
Remember, this
information is aggregated
from all the projects being
monitored by your Workspace.
This gives you a single place
to see everything you're
responsible for managing.
Now right now, you might be
thinking, well, that's great,
but I have a default
namespace in every cluster.
How will I ever find
out what I need?
Well, there's a really
cool filtering feature
that will help you to
find exactly what you're
looking for.
For example, if you have
a copy of the front end
service running in three
different clusters,
the filter lets you select
the exact one you want.
Once you apply the
filter, the entire
dashboard its filtered to match.
One of the things that's
been hard to do in the past
is to get an aggregated
view of the data.
For example, what does my
resource utilization looks
like across my namespace?
This new view makes
it really easy
to get this kind of aggregation.
And it'll scale no
matter how many resources
are being monitored, even if
you have thousands of pods
across hundreds of namespaces.
But if you do want to see
all of those resources,
you can click View All.
That will let you see all of
the entities in that category.
If that list is
too overwhelming,
you can filter from here, too.
At any point, you can
select a row in the table
to get its details.
For example, click a pod
to open its detailed panel.
This view has everything
you need in one place--
metadata about the
resource, any incidence
that it has triggered, and
metric and log data, too.
Having a single place to
access all this information
makes understanding what's
going on much easier.
On the Metrics
tab, you can easily
select a smaller subset
of time if you're trying
to zero in on an anomaly.
Just drag the rectangle
on the chart that includes
the time you want to focus on.
From any Metric chart, you can
then create a learning policy
by clicking on that link.
This is a great way to quickly
get started with the learning
GKE entities right in context.
You can also get right to the
logs of the resource you've
selected.
For example, select a pod
and click on the Logs tab
to see the most
recent logs for it.
If you're troubleshooting an
issue, you can filter the logs.
For example, you might only want
to see error logs to figure out
why a pod is crashing.
To get more details, click on
the Open and Logging button.
That will open the
new Logs Viewer
with your query
pre-populated and executed.
This really makes
it very easy to know
exactly what's going
on with your workloads
without having to figure out how
to select the resource you're
looking for.
You may recall that we
covered using logging
with your GKE
clusters and workloads
in an earlier episode.
We'll link to that below if
you haven't seen it already.
Thanks for joining me today.
We took a look at the new
GKE Monitoring Dashboard
and learned how to use it
in-context capabilities
to set up a learning and pull
up logs for our workload.
Thanks for watching, and
come back soon for more.
This is a Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]